es un golpe de nieve una tormenta que
paraliza la costa este de eeuu la región
del país con mayor densidad de población
son zonas con una acumulación de nieve
que se estima estará entre 31 y 61
centímetros es desde pensilvania sammen
en donde el fenómeno climático ha
golpeado con más fuerza según el
servicio de meteorología y es la gran
manzana uno de los puntos de mayor
afectación
algunas personas tienen un lugar en
donde quedarse otras no lo mejor que se
puede hacer es intentar sobrevivir en
las calles más del 90% de los vuelos en
la ciudad de nueva york se cancelaron
pero lo que más preocupa es la
suspensión de la vacunación es algo que
se registra en el estado y la ciudad de
nueva york además de nueva jersey y
massachusetts datos esto es la tormenta
está afectando nuestro esfuerzo de
vacunación y necesitamos mantener a
salvo a la gente no queremos vecinos
especialmente adultos mayores
saliendo bajo condiciones inseguras para
vacunarse sabemos que podemos reagendar
la cita es muy rápido porque claro
tenemos nuestros suministros o algo
las consecuencias de la nieve llegan
hasta la política la confirmación de
alejandro mayorkas nacido en cuba se
tuvo que aplazar en el senado y con ella
su entrada en la historia como el primer
latino al frente del departamento de
seguridad nacional bajo la
administración de john biden también se
tuvo que suspender un discurso del
presidente previsto para el lunes en el
que el mandatario pretendía detallar sus
prioridades en política exterior